welcome everyone this is part three in
our series on methods and metrics we're
going to be talking about metrics for
assessing natural language generation
systems we previously talked about
classifier metrics and the issues seem
relatively straightforward as you'll see
assessment for energy systems is
considerably more difficult let's
actually begin with those fundamental
challenges maybe the most fundamental of
all is that in natural language there is
more than one effective way to say most
things the data sets we have might have
one or a few good examples of how
something should be said
but that's just a sample of the many
ways in which we could communicate
effectively and that leaves us with
fundamental open questions about what
comparisons we should make and how we
should assess so-called mistakes
relatedly there's just an open question
of what we're actually trying to measure
is it fluency
or truthfulness or communicative
effectiveness or some blend of the three
as we think about different metrics we
might find that they capture one or a
few of these and completely neglect
others and that's sure to shape the
trajectory of our project and the actual
goals that we achieve so we have to be
really thoughtful about what we're
actually trying to measure in the space
let's begin with perplexity i would say
what perplexity has going for it is that
is it is at least very tightly knit to
the structure of many of the models that
we work with in nlg
so the core calculation
is that given some sequence x of length
n
and a probability distribution p
the perplexity of x relative to that
distribution p is the product of the
inverse of all the assigned
probabilities and then we take an
average here there are many ways to
express this calculation and many ways
to connect with information theoretic
measures let me defer those issues for
just a second and i'll try to build up
an intuition just after getting through
the core calculation so that's
perplexity and then when we do token
level perplexity right we want to assign
perplexity to individual examples we
need to normalize by the length of those
examples and we do that in log space in
order to capture a kind of geometric
mean which is arguably more appropriate
for comparing probability values
and then if we want the complex the
perplexity for an entire corpus we again
use a geometric mean of all the token
level perplexity predictions
and that gives us a single quantity over
an entire batch of examples
what are the properties of perplexity
well its bounds are one to infinity with
one the best so we would like to
minimize
perplexity it is equivalent to the
exponentiation of the cross entropy loss
that's the tight connection with models
that i wanted to call out we often work
with language models that use across
entropy loss and you can see that they
are directly optimizing for a quantity
that is proportional to perplexity and
that can be useful as a kind of getting
a direct insight into the nature of your
model's predictions
what value does it encode well i think
it's simple does the model assign high
probability to the input sequences that
is does it assign low perplexity to the
input sequences
the weaknesses there are many actually
first it's heavily dependent on the
underlying vocabulary to see that
imagine an edge case where we take every
word in the vocabulary and map it to a
single unk token in that case we will
absolutely minimize perplexity but our
system will be useless in that edge case
you can see that i could reduce
perplexity simply by changing the size
of my vocabulary that's a way that you
could kind of gain this metric
inadvertently
as a result of that we can't really
commit comparisons across data sets
because of course they can have
different vocabularies and different
intrinsic notions of perplexity
and it's also even tricky to make
comparisons across models you can see
that in my first weakness there
if we do compare models we need to fix
the data set and make sure that the
differences between the models are not
inherently shaping the range of
perplexity values that we're likely to
see
let's move on now into a family of what
you might think of as n-gram based
methods for assessing nlg systems
beginning with the word error rate so
the fundamental thing here will be an
edit distance measure
and therefore you can see word error
rate as a kind of family of measures
depending on the choice of the edit
distance function which we would just
plug in
the word error rate is the distance
between the actual sequence x and some
predicted sequence spread normalized by
the length of the actual sequence
and if we would like the word error rate
for an entire corpus it's easy to scale
it up but there's one twist here the way
that's standardly calculated is that the
numerator
is the sum of all the distances between
the actual and predicted sequences
not normalized as it was up here for the
word error rate the normalization that
happens over the entire corpus it's the
sum of all the lengths of the actual
strings in the corpus so we have one
average as opposed to taking an average
of averages
the properties of the word error rate
its bounds are zero to infinity and we
would like to minimize it so zero is the
best
the value encoded is similar to f scores
we would like to answer the question how
a line is the predicted sequence with
the actual sequence and i've invoked f
scores here because if our edit distance
measure has notions of insertion and
deletion they play roles that are
analogous to precision and recall
the weaknesses well first we have just
one reference text here i called out
before that there are often many good
ways to say something whereas here we
can make only a single comparison
and it's also maybe this is more
fundamental word airaid is a very
syntactic notion just consider comparing
text like it was good it was not good
and it was great they're likely to have
the identical word error rates even
though the first two to differ
dramatically in their meanings and the
first and the third are actually rather
similar in their meanings that semantic
notion of similarity is unlikely to be
reflected in the word error rate
let's move now to blue scores this is
another
based metric but it's going to try to
address the fact that we want to make
comparisons against multiple human
created reference texts
it has a notion of precision in it but
it's called modified engram precision
let me walk you through an example and
hopefully that will motivate it imagine
we had the candidate that had just seven
instances of the word thought in it
we have two reference texts presumably
written by humans the cat is on the mat
and there is a cat on the mat
the modified precision takes for the
token the the maximum number of times
that the occurs in any reference text
and that's two the reference one here
and it divides that by the number of
times that the appears in the candidate
which is seven that will give us 2 over
7 as the modified engram one gram
precision score for this candidate
there's also a brevity penalty which
will play the role of something like
recall in the blue scoring so we have a
quantity r which is the sum of all the
minimal absolute length differences
between candidates and reference
we have c which is the total length of
all the candidates and then we said that
the brevity penalty is 1 if c is greater
than r otherwise it's an exponential
decay off of the ratio of r and c
and again that will play kind of the
notion of recall and then the blue score
is simply the product of that brevity
penalty
with the sum of the weighted modified
n-gram precision values for each engram
value n considered so we'd probably go
one through four that's a standard set
of n grams to consider we would sum up
all those notions of modified n-gram
precision for each n
and possibly weight them differently
depending on how we want to value one
grams two grams three grams and four
grams
so that's the blue scoring what are its
properties its bounds are zero and one
and one is the best but we have really
no expectation that any system will
actually achieve one because even
comparisons among human translations or
human created texts will not have a blue
score of one
the value encoded is an appropriate
balance of modified precision and recall
under the guise of that brevity penalty
it's very similar to the word error rate
in that sense but it seeks to
accommodate the fact that there are
typically multiple suitable outputs for
a given input and that's a real strength
of blue scoring
the weaknesses well this team has argued
that blue scores just failed to
correlate with human um scores for
translations and that's kind of worrying
because blue scores were originally
motivated in the context of machine
translation and the issues that they
identify are like it's very sensitive to
engram order in a way that human
intuitions are not
and it's insensitive to the type of the
engrams so again just consider
comparisons like that dog the dog and
that toaster those will likely have very
similar blue scores um but that dog and
that dog are just inherently much more
similar than that dog and that toaster
and virtue of the fact that that and the
just the difference at the level of
functional vocabulary versus dog and
toaster is a really contentful change
and then as we move into topics that are
more closely aligned with nlu we
possibly have an even more worrying
picture so this team argues that blue is
just a fundamentally incorrect measure
for assessing dialogue systems and that
could be an indicator that it's not
going to be appropriate for many kinds
of nlg tasks in nlu
that's just a sample of two engram-based
metrics i thought i'd mention a few more
to give you a framework for making some
comparisons so i mentioned the word
errate that's fundamentally edit
distance from a single reference text
blue as we've seen is modified precision
and a brevity penalty kind of recall
motion comparing against many reference
texts
rouge is a recall focused variant of
blue that's focused on assessing
summarization systems
meteor is interestingly different
because it's trying to push past simple
engram matching and capture some
semantic notions it's a unigram based
measure that does an alignment measure
between not only exact matches of
unigrams but also stem versions and
synonyms really trying to bring in some
semantic aspects
and cider is similar this is going to be
even a more semantic notion because it's
going to do its comparisons in vector
space it's kind of approximately a
weighted cosine similarity between tf
idf vectors created from the corpus
finally in closing i just wanted to
exhort you all to think about more
communication based metrics in the
context of nlu for nlu it's worth asking
whether you can evaluate your system
based on how well it actually
communicates in the context of a real
world goal as opposed to just comparing
different strings that are inputs and
reference texts and we've actually seen
an example of that in our assignment and
bake off on color reference we didn't
really assess how well your system could
reproduce the utterances that were in
the corpus rather our fundamental notion
was listener accuracy which was keying
into a communication goal how well is
your system actually able to take
messages and use them to figure out what
the speaker was referring to in a simple
color context and for much more on that
and a perspective on a lot of these
issues i encourage you to check out this
paper that was led by ben newman it
began as a course project for this class
and grew into a really successful paper